I gotta ask you about Bots because it to
me it's like super interesting and
you've played a lot of bots at different
levels
uh you have a video called the advanced
chess Bots are terrifying uh so what's
the difference between playing humans
and Bots like you mentioned this Nelson
bot yeah that brings his Queen out I
think rated 16. over 1400 okay at 12 40.
I think so like there's a style to those
what uh what's the difference between
the way Bots play and the way humans
play a lot of people prefer playing Bots
because they have anxiety playing other
humans it's a very legitimate thing
interesting a lot of beginners they they
don't like live chess they get nervous
ELO anxiety you get close to your
highest ever rating you panic happens to
me too yeah happens to me even now
so definitely Bots they're somehow more
reliable or something yeah they're I
don't know but that's it's a big thing
it's a big thing and the popularity of
that video shows that people enjoy
watching you play chess bots so
uh I'm gonna demystify this this might
be shocking
those Bots are all the same but for the
most part you could just program a bot
to make mistakes at a certain moment
you could program a bot to spend less
time on certain moves and it's gotten
sophisticated enough that you can
basically program it to play at whatever
more or less level
that a human plays at you say I'll play
it at 1800 level
so it's programmed to throw in mistakes
the problem is
and this is why it's all beginners to
not play Bots
because Bots are programmed in the
following way
beginner Bots or like literal toddlers
they have no understanding whatsoever
they will literally lose all their
pieces but they won't lose all their
pieces and make mistakes the way
beginners do beginners actually know how
to start a game they just struggle
the first eight moves nine moves their
mistakes are very different than Bob
plays completely outlandish types of
mistakes that you cannot pick up in
terms of a pattern standpoint because no
actual humans play like that they should
move their Queen to the opposite side of
the board for no reason you can take it
yeah it's not even a blunder it's almost
like Randomness it's completely random
and this problem extends further because
Advanced Bots will play an opening
completely reasonably
and then just hang a rook
which okay maybe happens but that's not
exactly how you get to 1800 at 1800
that's a very strong level of the game
you know your openings very well you
start navigating the middle game based
on already things that you remember and
then basically one side chooses a bad
plan and the other side chooses a better
plan and one thing leads to another
nobody's just recreationally hangs all
their pieces which is the way Bots are
kind of programmed to play but some of
those bots in that video were I remember
playing them
and uh they were they yeah they were
nuts uh they were out calculating me
every time I thought I had a trick in
two three second moment of thought it
would just play the best move and
sometimes that also happens it gets into
a dead Loop where it just starts
bulldozing you and it can't stop so it
made its mistakes already yeah it's
programmed to make only a few
and then it just bulldozes you the rest
of the way interesting I mean that's
that's why I I played with stockfish a
bunch
so I got um
I built for myself a bunch of different
chess experiments recently I had to do
with the chest plane bot uh but I also
built the infinite chessboard where it
was stockfish was playing like an
infinite number of chess games
and one of the parameters that was
interesting to play with is how long it
gets to think about a move and how that
affects the rating of the thing oh I've
I did that a little bit so that's a
tricky one I'm sure people know how to
do that well but it's trick it's not
trivial to to understand like what there
must be a good formula for it but it's
also interesting to think about like a
controlled number of blunders
but it's probably better
the control number of blunders is not a
good way to build the bot yeah it's yeah
for training purposes at least the time
the time per move is probably better but
the craziest thing is I did that a
couple of my of my devs were helping me
with the build like uh I'm scaling my
courses into a better just learning
platform essentially we've done a lot of
different experiments with stockfish
which I'm even happy to get into here
um and uh stockfish making moves in 0.1
millisecond plays better than a human
which is disgusting and disturbing
frankly because that's crazy like you
can't react to a car stopping in front
of you anywhere near that fast and yeah
so the reason I was interested in that
is because when you have an a very large
chessboard you have
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of game going on at the same time
you have to the like think of the
minimum amount of thinking per move that
you can uh allow for and it does it does
seem it's damn good uh at least to my
eye basically at the lowest possible
setting you can give it so yeah it's
incredible it's incredible what boss
you're able to do now it's
as far as I know as primarily machine
learning based stockfish so stockfish
move to machine learning completely it's
not doing search
as far as I know yeah this is where you
you lose me a bit but the move Discovery
and evaluation is what's been changing
in in the way starfish works so it's
discovering of moves and then the way it
looks forward and then evaluates
positions that has changed but Matthew
Sadler who wrote the book Game Changer
about Alpha zero yeah that that he
explains it significantly better but
that's the way I think it it works
what did that make you feel when you
first saw Alpha zero play I was excited
I I didn't have any any sort of
existential thoughts I enjoyed watching
it completely destroy openings that
people thought were good
uh and it
it that experiment though has does have
some caveat in the sense that
I think Alpha zero was playing with a
full tank of servers and I think
stockfish wasn't which I think is what
one of the things people point out they
weren't playing since then they were
able to demonstrate much less yeah
uh
but also Alpha zero stopped developing
um they stopped developing it yes
which which sucks but again from their
perspective From deepmind's perspective
it's like all right well we took on this
really tricky game did something
honestly incredible they won
they won I mean well not just one I mean
they did it without any human
supervision so like uh without any
training on human expert games so only
through self-play which
I mean that's what learning is about
it's like it's what you think of as a
child a human child a toddler learning
from
you know somewhat nothing and becoming a
capable human that's that's what we
think of when we think about
intelligence so the fact that it's able
to play itself and become the best
player in the world at the game of Go
and all kinds of games it's just
incredible and obviously that inspired
the modern stockfish yeah now to do the
same all the same kind of self-play
methods